on va commencer par dire bonjour à
Emy bonjour
Emy qu'est-ce que vous vous
souvenez de ce qu'on a dit sur l'image
la petite
[Musique]
fille pourquoi tu crois qu'elle est
fâchée par parce que elle a cassé la
maison de le petit le grand garçon qui
est triste ah tu penses qu'elle est
fâchée parce que un un des garçons
casser la maison du petit garçon qui est
tr c'est
[Musique]
ça alors si on sait pas mettre un mot
sur ses
émotions on peut pas comprendre ce que
c'est que l'empathie on peut pas
comprendre qui sont les autres et
comment interagir avec eux les élèves
ont un potentiel de de compréhension de
la situation sociale en fait que je leur
soupçonnais pas à les voir en classe à
au quotidien image vous vous souvenez
c'est la première image Adriel de sa
valise pour qu'on la regarde
ensemble ah tu
[Musique]
penses vas-y raconte-nous la méthode
free for mobbery repose sur quatre
valeurs fondamentales la tolérance le
respect la bienveillance et le courage
et cette valeur de courage et pour moi
une valeur
essentielle c'est le
courage de dire non euh le courage de
défendre un camarade qui est embêté par
un autre un autre enfant
euh c'est l'apprentissage du
consentement c'est l'ami de tous les
enfants de de la classe et même de
l'école vous le passez gentiment les uns
et les
[Musique]
autres allez ça fait plus que
TR dans sa
[Musique]
maison